veganism is going out of fashion
meatless Farm announced R production
beyond meat shares crashed 95% uh most
vegan companies in this country lack of
consumer demand now I think people have
got a bit fed up with it I think one of
the reasons is they're fed up with being
shouted at you you're one of these
people that runs into restaurants and
plays you know sounds from screaming
animals and avatars and so on I know you
care passionately about it I think he's
very off-putting it's bit like the just
stop oil protesters doing a lot of their
stuff it just annoys people has the
opposite effect to what you hope no I
don't think so at all I think it brings
more attention to the animal Holocaust
animals are subjected to rape torture
enslavement abuse and murder and I'm
bringing light to that and I saying why
would you use the word okay why use the
word holocaust Holocaust is the mass
extermination of more than six million
Jewish people by Adolf het Nazis well
one Holocaust in history why would you
why would you people know that as the
Holocaust why would you use that kind of
very emotive language knowing it would
offend a lot of people well it's just a
factual statement if you look at the
definition of a Holocaust it is LA or
destruction on a mass scale multiple
holocausts have occurred throughout
human history and non-human animals can
be subjected to the same atrocities that
humans can in fact it's the largest
Holocaust in history with three trillion
individuals brutally murdered every year
for human food consumption all right
Tommy you're from a ranching family uh I
don't know about you I just find I don't
mind people being vegan if you don't
want to eat me it's absolutely fine like
get some of the reasons why they don't
want to personal choice you know they
care about animals and so on although I
would point out animals eat a lot of
animals just for the record naturally um
what do you feel about this whole vegan
debate are we getting bored with it it
seems to me from all the sales and the
UK and stuff it's kind of going out of
fashion like it was a fat for a lot of
people they've gone back to munching
meat well veganism is an
e re yeah I think a lot of people
realize that it wasn't in fact the
healthier choice because when they
choose this beyond meat or these other
substitutes it's actually just packed
with different fillers so it's not
actually this cleaner option like a lot
of people thought at the onset of the
whole vegan craze but I got to tell you
speaking of the animal Holocaust which I
think is a ridiculous thing to say I'm
from a ranching family I'm from a
ranching State there's nobody that cares
more for their animals than those in the
ranching and farming communities now I'm
against Factory ranching and farming as
well by the way I think that that's
atrocious I'm an animal lover but as
somebody who comes from a ranching
family I can tell you that ranchers and
Farmers care for their livestock dearly
yes it does at the end of the day turn
into a product for human consumption but
that doesn't mean that it's always
inhumane that it's always disgusting
that this animal Holocaust or genocide
as your guest was referring to it as
it's also really annoying to me when
people try to say that animals are
causing climate change I mean if you
don't want to eat animals because you
love animals or you have a health reason
that prevents you from eating animals
that's fine but this whole environmental
craze that we need to get rid of animals
because they're causing climate change
that's also a step too far and part of
the reason why this whole vegan craze is
going out the window yeah and you know
be grills said recently I was a vegan
quite a few years he said but I thought
it was good for the environment I
thought it was good for my health and
through time and experience and
knowledge and study I realized I was
wrong on both counts it was bad for the
environment bad for his health he was
never a vegan in the first place
veganism is an ethical view against anal
abuse and murder if you're against
animal abuse and murder you never
contribute it to a again he wrote a
vegan cookbook it wasn't actually a
vegan cookbook it contained animal abuse
and saying bad girls was a fake vegan
he never was a vegan he was a vegan no
AB you're saying he's a liar he's not a
liar no well I've looked at the cookbook
Animal product you may not have liked
the fact that he went back to eating
meat but he was a vegan for quite a
while well people go by that label all
the time but if they actually truly hold
their ethical view against animal abuse
and murder then they would never turn
back on veganism you know Tommy over
here I railed against uh uh vegan
sausage rolls I didn't like the way they
appropriated the language of meat
products I don't think vegan companies
should be allowed to use words like
sausage rolls or steaks because that's
meat yeah exactly and they're filled
with soy and fillers and other
disgusting things that you actually
don't want to put into your body and
meat tastes good that's why all of these
fake meat companies try to make it taste
like meat it never actually comes to
fruition because it still tastes like
crap and I would also point out during
covid when we were having shortages in
the grocery store if you looked for meat
it was sometimes hard to find at least
here in the US but that beyond meat crap
that was always available because people
don't want it the consumers are deciding
that they want maybe an organic option
maybe a free range option but people
still want to eat meat and you can eat
meat and respect animals at the same
time it can be done it's been done since
the dawn of time but we are beyond
beyond meat now we're going back to
munching meat I love meat I won't be Bes
otherwise and I think there are better
tactics than running into restaurants
and playing noises of screaming animals
personally why are vegans so
angry well um he he made a statement
saying uh the vegans are angry and angry
but he carried on and banned all vegans
from his restaurant because of one
simple complaint he's allowed to yeah
he's allowed to ban a whole group of
people from a chef who's just sick of
tailoring to vegan people who want to
have all this stuff and get angry about
me listen listen listen wait a second he
he got a two uh he got a two star review
when he was on um Great British menu
right he ripped off his mic smashed up
the studio and said that he wanted to
kill the guy for giving him a two star
review of a fish dish that he made he
didn't ban all Fish Eaters to from his
on you he didn't ban allish Joy Joey
Joey Joey we're going to get personal
you were a gang member so don't take the
high moral gr of Smashing something up
em Em I'm completely honest about
there's been document don't take the
high moral ground about losing his
temper you were literally in a gang I
was 10 years ago 10 years sober now
you're going to use I'm just say if
you're going to get personal with but
anyways I don't walk around with uh dead
baby pigs facing them like that like
does that look like someone who really
gives a d
you know and that's his profile picture
looking at a dead p a Australia second I
just want to say in Australia pigs are
killed in gas Chambers okay they caus
pigs they're horrible have you seen
footage from inside a gas chamber I
recently exposed one in the UK they
scream to death and beg for mercy in per
there's a gas chamber called linly belly
pork right and this guy serves pork at
his restaurants and why would you be
more upset that of a little complaint as
a shed then pigs being murdered let me
ask you okay let me ask you the question
that I asked a vegan activist the other
day which is that given that uh 80% or
90% of the world's armens come from
California where they're are made in the
involving the demolition of billions of
bees who get murdered how do you feel
about the little I don't get murdered
and that's completely false and I don't
know why how many billions many die in
in the pollination I've got the 2022
data right here they die mostly from
parasites and pest 66% die of varites or
other pest and parasites disease in the
making excuse armm and avocad they oh
they do do the data is here this here
you know where I read this here is data
from US Department of Agriculture you
know where I read this I read it in the
guardian the vegan Bible even the
guardian admitted that you vegans who
eat avocados and AR 6.7% this is not
don't care about the little guys we boy
billions of bees mured you don't care
where do those bees come from H where do
those bees come in America they come
from all over the country the commercial
honey industry that's true and boyot
what a be vegan's boycott go on the
commercial honey industry why don't you
boycot armor avado because I don't see a
reason to most of the bees are dying
from
mites do you see po re okay listen only
6% die from pesticides so it's not
really a rights violation they're not
murdering the be is the be big pig a big
pig makes you cry a little be you don't
care no listen there's no reason to be
upset about sometimes from why aren't
you angry at the M hang on Joey Shou
over each other sometimes 50 billion
bees die in six weeks to give you vegan
literally
just out that's not true agricultural
stat from America true read read the
guardian I read it in an article an
anecdote so it must be true listen Joey
how long have you been a vegan uh 10
years do you actually because you seem
quite agitated to me like you want a bit
about nonsense about bees being murdered
when they die from mon they are murdered
they're murdered you're it's Crown
Behavior but you think in a way you
represent what I feel about V you're all
quite angry Are You Against Animal
Cruelty P yes then why do you support
animal cruelty when you support the me
don't I've defended the bees for years
no well they're not murdered they die
billions of bees are murdered so that
you V can eat arm and AV honey where
they where they hired from they have no
respect for meat eaters uh but if we
were doing the same thing to them they'd
all go nuts right wouldn't you you'll go
nuts if I came running into your little
vegan hell holes and began screaming
abuse you'd all throw your toys out the
Bram as you do do on a daily
basis I'm not throwing my toys out the
pram right now P I'm I'm loving this to
be honest what you what are you loving
I'm loving this open conversation that
we're having about it's actually quite
why do you have to go and and do a
restaurant and disrupt our business
disrupt the customers other people that
want to eat the meat other people that
want to enjoy themselves they want to go
and have a night out uh I don't have any
problems with you guys coming to our
restaurants and ordering a vegan dish
in fact in January we always do a
veganuary and we go through a lot of
different um ingredients to create menus
for you guys I don't understand why we
have to suffer uh your mentality of
coming to our restaurants and trying to
disrupt the customers that are having a
fantastic time and they want to eat the
steak what's the answer it's actually a
good question Alo and actually it's
fantastic that you create fantastic
vegan dishes the fact of the matter is
when we look at high-end restaurants you
know Salt Bay Restaurant Mana up in
Manchester that was also descripted the
weekend these are symbols of a broken
system you know why because he makes
nice symbols of a broken system where
you know there's 1500 quid getting
charged for why is he making millions
around the world I was I was in one of
his restaurants last week in Kata I
loved it fantastic but he served me I a
CP I of him yeah I was waiting for you
to show it up I was wondering how long
it would take was me doing his little uh
salt trick he taught me you w you weren
very good at it he then actually took it
in front of me and he fed me actually
directly fed me the meat into my mouth
it was delicious loved it fine Lov it I
would invite any V but if You' run in
and tried to interrupt and just ruin
everyone's night I would have done what
those VES did just thrown you out that's
absolutely fine what's the point of it
all what does it achieve none of you
make me want to change my mind I just
think what annoying little squits
honestly I do it's the same when you're
chucking paint at Van gol painting it's
the same when you're tying yourself to
fuel pumps or hanging yourself on
Bridges stopping people using Dart for
tunnel it's all the same you're just all
too annoying so the British public don't
like annoying people and they don't like
their lives being disrupted they want
their freedom to have a choice the
choice as I had in Qatar last week to
have salt Bay Restaurant
you to do this to my mouth can you
imagine someone coming in this is
disrupting your evening have we got the
clip we haven't got the clip oh what sh
oh you run it okay no but can you
imagine you coming to our restaurants
and and then you get
some people coming to your table and
trying to disrupt your evening it's it's
abuse I'm going to start Ry I'm going to
start running into vegan restaurants
that's fine go for being annoying
grabbing tables and so you can't eat
your gr and just see how you not like it
I'm going to go to your house and chop
paint all over it you've got a right to
place oh you've got me another one take
it off your bingo fastic take your but
where's the salt where's where's it
won't need any of this GR F put that to
one side but I will have a bit of steak
just to you didn't s it though you see
all you've achieved is you've made me
want to do this just that's absolutely
fine you go for
[Music]
it do you know do you know how many
steaks he's had from my restaurant yeah
a lot a lot a lot but here's my point I
love eating steak I'm not going to stop
eating steak Yeah and the the very last
thing on Earth that will stop me eating
steak is people like you with your pasty
faces running into our restaurants
telling us to stop eating steak the very
last thing I'm going to do ab you don't
represent to me Vitality or good health
you just all look like you want a good
bit of steak that's absolutely fine
you're fully entitled to that opinion
and as I've just said earlier your right
to protest if you want to run into the
ex Rebellion right my mates you're all
like interwoven you said before we came
on what like a like a wool and blank are
you connected or not no so we're assist
movement assist what's that Rebellion
sounds a bit sex no
we we have you know Common go goals you
know what goals irritating people such
such as tackling the climate and
ecological emergencies which you know
I'm sure all of us what did you think of
Megan and Harry using a private plane
off there we go Megan marle that's
another one four for n now I'm not I'm
not going to give you that what did you
think of them using a private plane to
to go to this uh award
show you must be furious right it's
incredible how you manage are F to turn
this into oh let's dump on
your agenda PE
off I just wonder whether I just wonder
whether do you feel do you feel angry
they used a private plane or
not what we should have is Affordable
Travel for but they they Ed private what
we should have is Travel Systems do you
criticize them for using a private plane
or not you know or because they
the using a I would I would have much
preferred you know why you can't don't
you know cuz this again hypocrisy you
can't because you Nathan M you don't
want to read a headline tomorrow saying
Nathan McGovern from animal Rebellion
slams Megan and Harry for using private
plane you don't want to say it because
like them you're a flaming hypocrite
you'd rather go in there we go you've
got me a column you'd rather you rather
go you'd rather go into restaurants like
Aldos or salt Bays or whatever and just
make a nuisance of yourselves because
it's easier my problem with vegans is
this I I bet you're a you probably like
alans do you oh no no you're not going
to do the Almond avocado with me no this
is B do this is boring it may be boring
I actually find the vegan assault on
Meed is boring so do you eat avocados
and armor I'm not assaulting do you eat
them anybody do you eat them I eat them
from Spain so you do you eat avocado
because the issues that you talk about
you drink what kind of milk do you drink
you're talking about the murder kind
milk you drink you talk about the murder
of Sawyer so okay yeah you talk about
the murder of bees in other interviews
because V don't care but you don't how
about the billions of carves and chicks
and piglets so you're a complete
hypocrite I'm not you are p no the
Hypocrites are the vegans in Munch away
on armonds and and the avocados and
stuff they don't give a damn about
billions of bees getting annihilated the
bees are the little guys and I had this
conversation time because that's the
hypocrisy I don't care you're obsessed
with this because you think it catches
proud and happy meat and
yogurt when you try and make out this
yogurt is the most evil thing that
anyone in the world I think your bunkers
we're in a six mass extinction we're
living it now you're behaving like a
news anchor on in the what you're
behaving like a news an on the fil don't
look up in the sixth last Extinction
you're deflecting all the time from the
world is not going to end because trying
to deflect because I eat yogur animals
are Factory farmed you're trying to
deflect from the fact world still here
veganism protects the environment we're
still here we are but how much long have
we got you've got kids you must care
about the climate crisis I let my kids
eat meat I let them eat yogurt and you
know what I don't think it's evil you
must care about the climate crisis and
you must be aware that the University of
Oxford has specifically stated that a
vegan diet it protects the environment
reduces you said you eat your you said
you got your eat almonds or avocados
from Spain which one from Spain which
one both I don't eat almonds how do they
get here how do they get here Boat Boat
really you sure yes I am sure you sure I
am absolutely sure really and how do you
think most vegans get most of their
armor avocados from California and how
do you think mosters get their they
don't get them from a boat they get them
on planers get they get them on planes
which guzzle up the environment do you
eat avocados yes but you care about all
these millions of bees being k no I care
about your hypocrisy about the little
guys rubbish most bees are killed
because of overuse of pesticides most of
pcid is due to the way that the land
F to that is not for animal that is not
true you're talking most of the bees get
killed in the pollination process and by
the way after they get killed you vegans
get all your armors avocados flown over
on these gas guzzling planes and my
point is I like to fly I like to eat
meat I like to eat yogurts I'm just fed
up with vegans trying to shame me for it
when you're all such Hypocrites when it
comes to the bees no you're not you're
against factory farming if you went
inside the Farms that I've been inside
and theas that I set up Viva the state
of the animals that I've seen them in
pigs dying in front of me if this makes
me evil you would not makes me evil I am
happy to be evil it's
disgusting it's
delicious love to see it that's it from
me whatever you're up to keep it
[Music]
creamy